the jurogan experience our communities
it's all over the place on youtube but
because of this current pandemic they
feel like there's this heightened sense
of responsibility that they have to
to control the narrative and that's
that's very disturbing to me and what's
even more disturbing to me is how people
when they agree with that narrative
don't understand where this all goes and
they're they're agreeing with that
censorship they're like yes censor those
people get rid of those voices deep
platform people that i disagree with and
they don't understand where this goes
it's like where people are saying the
people that have uh that have been
vaccinated that want a vaccine passport
yes we should have a vaccine passport
i've been vaccinated that's not going to
it's only going to help me i did my part
i i took one for the team and i went out
and got vaccinated to be a good citizen
those people who didn't [ __ ] them we
should have a vaccine that makes zero
sense but here's the problem with it the
vaccine passport it doesn't end there
it's going to keep going and it's going
to lead to some sort of a social
system you're going to have a social
credit system similar to what they have
it's going to happen in our lifetime 100
you're saying 100 it can happen are you
okay with that no okay so 100 can happen
in our lifetime because people will step
with it they will go as long as it
benefits them and as long as it aligns
with their ideology they will ignore the
dangers of a social credit system and
they will embrace it yeah if i would
never thought people would be look six
months ago the white house was saying
there's no way we would ever use some
sort of a vaccine mandate oh no but your
kamala said i would never take the
vaccine
yeah both of them said that yeah yeah
they both did but then once they got
into office six months ago they said we
would never
use a mandate we would never try to
force businesses or people to be
vaccinated now they are saying that now
they want you to do that do you see that
video where they're they're talking
about by talking about the hurricane
no
no
have you seen that jamie here i'll say
the one where the kids laughing here
i'll send you this one because this is
the funniest one because these these
guys were watching them say this
and as these guys are watching them say
this
uh it's just funny here i'm sending this
give me one second it's hurricane yeah
he's he's telling them they should get
vaccinated before the hurricane comes
it's it's obviously a joke right no it's
not a joke he's be he's being dead
serious but you got to watch this i just
said it to you jamie let's watch we'll
watch it on the screen we'll have a nice
laugh because
it's not that you shouldn't get
vaccinated that's not what i'm saying
it's just like the narrative is so
it's so overwhelming that it applies to
everything now it applies to the [ __ ]
hurricane play this give you some value
the state where hurricanes often strike
these two guys like florida or the gulf
coast or into texas
a vital part of preparing for hurricane
season is to get vaccinated now
everything is more complicated if you're
not vaccinated in a hurricane or natural
disaster hits how the hell does that
make any sense
okay
so so
people are just stepping in line you're
stepping you're not saying don't take
the vaccine that's not what you're
saying i think a lot of people should
take the vaccine okay so i got a story
for you here from for my personal land
my dad is 79 years old okay
uh conversation came about the vaccine
he said are you taking it i said i'm not
taking it i was in the army that's
in the army in the first day of going
into the army they gave you 11 air shots
when you go in
and you just go through literally you
watch 11 shots 11 shots and one day back
to back to back and you say don't move
if you move a literally get a scar i
mean i'll never forget this i was 18
years old so i've had plenty of vaccine
in myself it's probably why i'm a little
bit off but so my dad okay he says
should i get the vaccine i said dad it's
up to you what do you want to do this is
pat you know i'm 70 something years old
i said dad if you're 79 do what you
wanted this i want to get the vaccines
when i got the vaccine great i didn't
get the vaccine i got covered so he ends
up getting the vaccine and
two weeks ago he just got his negative
back from coven he got positive and he
got pneumonia my dad had 79
and he is okay he's done he scored away
he has nothing to worry about today
would it have been different if he
didn't have the vaccine i don't know
okay just like it would have most likely
would have been so he would have been
worse it made sense yeah he took the
vaccine and benefited a friend of mine
younger than my 20 years
in great shape
didn't have the shot didn't take the
shot he got vaccine he got covid and had
pneumonia was in a hospital for four
weeks literally he was hospitalized
right
uh for myself i didn't take the vaccine
there's a few reasons why i haven't
taken a vaccine yet that's my own reason
why i'm taking a vaccine yet but the
biggest challenge for me is
the conversation of being forced to take
the vaccine so nicki minaj i'm sure you
were kind of following the story with
what's going on with nicki minaj her
cousin's testicles her cousin's
testicles yeah in trinidad and and
people are saying are you kidding me
about these testicles so whether these
testicles are just massive or something
happened to them or was because of the
vaccine let's set that aside with the
testicles i've never heard of testicles
swelling
i've heard of other things but not
because the vaccine so
so okay so that's that part all right so
she goes up there and she says i don't
want to take it
on her life
joe you got to listen to her live it's
so funny because she puts the camera and
the camera is at the ceiling you never
see your face you're just talking it's
alive right
and she says let me get this straight
because uh she put it out on twitter
that i got a call from the white house
to go and have a meeting at the white
house with
uh the the health secretary and what do
you call it with fauci right meeting
with fauci
and she said i would like to come but i
would like it to be live uh instead of
me traveling i'd much rather now travel
is still alive and they say yeah we
don't mind doing a live we just don't
want it to be recorded she says no i
want it to be recorded because i want my
audience to see
whether this is you know some honest
with the audience they say well let us
think about it she has her pr rep on it
and her agent on the call so it's not
like she's by herself then the white
house comes back and says no we never
told you that you're going to be doing
this live right because she tweeted us
and i got a call from white house
and she says why can't i have the choice
to not do it why can't i not have the
choice the the biggest contradiction for
to not do the vaccines i don't want to
take the vaccine yes they're forcing her
to do it and you know you heard a couple
of the folks from uh i don't know what
it was when they came out and they said
who was the lady that we were talking
about she says i got 2 million followers
girl i'm not at your level with you know
22 million followers on twitter you know
you you can do better girl you ought to
be ashamed of yourself for doing this
because now people are not taking a
vaccine who said that to her who's the
joy uh uh what's her name oh joanne reed
uh yeah yeah i think that's what was and
so she comes back and she says just
because i don't want to do it i don't
want to do it so why do i have to do it
i may end up doing it because i have to
go on tour and i have to do this part
but
if you're going to appoint joe yourself
where you're talking about 100 this is
going to happen in our generation then i
ask you
are you okay with that i didn't say 100
it's going to happen i said 100 it could
happen that
we have a social credit score in this
country the same people that are
accepting a vaccine passport my position
is i do not believe once the government
has the ability to control your movement
what you do and when you do it if they
can put limitations on your freedom and
that is that is what it is that it makes
it easier to control people once they do
that i do not believe they're going to
leave it at a vaccine passage i agree
with you i think they're going to expand
it and i think the the next logical move
is some sort of a social credit score
and you'll look at a bunch of things
have you paid your taxes have you are
you in debt do you owe money on your
credit cards are you in default of loans
um have you been vaccinated have you
have you voted and all those things who
you voted for well that would be
problematic but all those things could
be
designed into a social credit program
yeah where you you could see in a person
who has poor social credit a person
who's been to jail for
you know armed robbery a person who owes
taxes that person would have a lower
credit score and they wouldn't be
allowed into certain buildings why is
this a bad thing
it's because it's control it's okay it's
having the ability to tell people what
they can and can't do having a
government if you're a free person
i mean you've made mistakes or you're
you know you're trying to do better in
your life but you've had some
horrible scenarios in your in your past
you're you're supposed to be free to try
to navigate and do better in your life
if you're restricted and very clearly
restricted by the a set of parameters
that's decided by other people that
doesn't have to do with law like it's
not like you need to be locked up
because you're a criminal you you have a
social credit score like they're
implementing in china what it does is it
keeps people scared and it keeps people
in line and it's a fantastic way to
control the population and that's what
it's used for should we do something
about it
i think talking about it is a good thing
i think talking about it like we're
talking about allowing people to
recognize that this is something that
could potentially happen you think that
the vaccine passport just six months ago
was conspiracy theory nonsense like
people like what the [ __ ] you talking
about you're not gonna have a vaccine
passport no one was no one was accepting
the fact that this was real this is
stuff that alex jones talked about but
now
it's a real thing l.a new york yeah it's
a real is la now oh yeah they just
announced it three days right after
newsome right after once announcing the
next day that's right the next day they
announced it how clever watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify